[موسيقى]
من العربيه احييكم وهذه اخبار المساء
نبداها بابرز العناوين
كل حرب هي تفاوض
تكشفوا عن وصولي اسلحه من كوريا الشماليه
لروسيا لدعم قتال مجموعه فاجنر في
اوكرانيا
العسكريه عن الولايات المتحده ويجدد
الدعوه لانشاء جيش اوروبي
[موسيقى]
طلاب جامعه افغانستان
في المعاهد والمكتبات
[موسيقى]
والبدايه من روسيا حيث شكك الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في كفاءه بطاريات بيت ريوت
التي تعتزم واشنطن ارسالها الى اوكرانيا
مقارنه بمنظمات
الروسيه قائلا ان موسكو تمتلك طرياق
لتدمير البيطريات بوتن عدا واشار الى
المسار الدبلوماسي للحلفي اوكرانيا مشيرا
الى ان روسيا لم ترفض التفاوض يوما وتسعى
لانهاء الحرب وليست تاجيجها متهما كيف
بانها هي التي ترفض الجلوس الى طاوله
الحوار
[موسيقى]
انظمه باتريوت قديمه بما فيه الكفايه ولا
تعمل كما تعمل انظمه اس 300 مثلا ومع ذلك
من يجابه هنا ينطلق من ان هذا السلاح
دفاعي وسناخذ هذا في الحسبان ببساطه وسنجد
له ترياقا ومن يفعل ذلك يبطل ابدا لزعي
فقط سنحطم منظومه الباتريوت وسيحتاج الغرب
الى جلب اسلحه اخرى
[موسيقى]
اليه طورنا اسلحه الجيش الروسي للدفاع
وليس الهجوم سنزيد من قدراتنا العسكريه
باضافه اسلحه متطوره مع بدايه السنه روسيا
تثق في تحقيق اهدافها في اوكرانيا ولا
مجال للتراجع
وبتزامني مع اختتام زياره الرئيس
الاوكراني الى الولايات المتحده اكد
لكرملين ان واشنطن تخوض حربا بالوكاله ضد
روسيا في اوكرانيا
للولايات المتحده يصفها داعيم بالتاريخيه
وتصفها موسكو
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا
مواصفات السلام
[موسيقى]
زياره بعد ايام من زياره الروسيه اقلقت
كيف والغرب حاطه فيها بوتر
على موجه التسليح الجديده
[موسيقى]
قرابه وعشره اشهر منذ بدا الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا بدا الطرفان بتحسين
القدراتهم العسكريه شيئا فشيئا وابقى
تطلبه تغيرات ارض المعركه روسيا زادت من
قدراتها العسكريه بنسبه 30% واوكرانيا
تسعى الى الحصري على منظومه متطوره
والصواريخ بعيده المدى
هكذا وزراء وخارجيه مجموعه السبع
الالتزامه بتوفير المعدات العسكريه
ودفاعيه لاوكرانيا وباستمرار ممارسه
الضغوط على روسيا لوقف الحرب واعتبر وزراء
خارجيه مجموعه السبع استخدام روسيا الغذاء
والطاقه كسلاح هو امر غير مقبول مؤكدين
تامين لاستقرار الماليه الفوري لاوكرانيا
ودعم تعا فيها اقتصاديا
واضافوا انهم سيرفضون عقوبات على بلاروسيا
حال تدخلها المباشر في الحرب مطالبين
بيلاروسيا بوقف دعمها للجيش الروسي فورا
بدوره قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان
بلاده عازمه على استخدام جميع التدابير
المناسبه لرضع الهجمات الروسيه على
اوكرانيا جوا او برا او بحرا وقلب لينكين
ان الولايات المتحده مستعده لاتخاد
اجراءات اضافيه ستكون لها عواقب وخيمه على
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وداعمه في
الحرب الاوكرانيه
المحلل السياسي
اهلا بك في هذه النشره روسيا تقلل من
اهميه منظومه بيتريات لكن امريكا متفوقه
عسكريه
منظومه عسكريه مهمه جدا لماذا تقلل روسيا
من هذه من هذا السلاح الردعي
تحياتي
ليس فقط
لان هناك عدد من العيوب كما يقول الخبراء
العسكريون منها عجز هذه المنظومات عن
التعامل مع مثلا مسيرات تحلق الارتفاعات
منخفضه جدا هذا اولا ثانيا او وقت نشر هذه
المنظومات يزيده عنها بالنسبه لصواريخ 3
بسته مرات نشر صواريخ 300 يمكن ان يتم
خلال خمس دقائق بينما نشر باتريوت يتطلب
حوالي نصف ساعه وهذا الامر كما يقول
الخبراء مهم جدا اثناء العمليات العسكريه
التي تتطور بصرعه
وبالتالي روسيا همم طبعا همم كانت تعلم
مسبقا بان هذه الصواريخ
هذه المنظومات الصاروخيه سوف يتم تسليمها
الى اوكرانيا وهي تتعامل بهدوء تام لانها
تعرف همم ان هناك جرياقا كما جاء في كلمه
الرئيس الروسي وهناك وسائل همم يعني
يمكنها او كفيله بمواجهتها فيما اذا اقتدت
الضروره بذلك
في اوكرانيا وفي هكذا اسلحه موجوده تعتب
لماذا اذا تحتاج روسيا الى مسيرات ايرانيه
الصنع والان هناك حديث عن صفقه اسلحه من
كوريا الشماليه تريدها روسيا اذا اذا ما
كانت قادره على الحرب في اوكرانيا
اولا هذه الانباء لم تؤكدها مصادر رسميه
روسيه ثانيا طبعا الرئيس الروسي منذ يومين
اثناء اجتماعي بالقيادات العسكريه ركز على
اهميه المسيرات في هذه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه كما تسمى باوكرانيا اييي ربما حفظ
لارواح المقاتلين لارواح العسكريين الذين
يحاربون في اوكرانيا وبالتالي هذا الامر
منطقي تماما وهو ربما بمثابه استنتاج تم
التواصل اليه خلال 10 اشهر من العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه ان هناك حاجه ماسه الى
استخدام الموسيقى
تحتاج لايران لتصنع هكذا مسيرات طيب الان
هناك تصعيد في الخطاب العسكري بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا احيانا
خلف هذا التصعيد في الكلام يكون هناك
ابواب للتفاوض هل من التفاوض خلف الكواليس
ممكن ان يبدا
ولو يعني كان مواضيع بعض الاتصالات
الروسيه الامريكيه كما قال ممثله الطرفين
لم يتطرقوا لموضوع اوكرانيا الا انه كان
من الواضح ان الحديث طبعا يدور لمحاله عن
هذا الملف وهو الاهم الان في العلاقات
الدوليه وكذلك في العلاقات بين روسيا
واشنطن رقم التصعيد الشديد لهذه العلاقات
الا ان هناك اتصالات سواء على مستوى اا
مديريه جهازين الاستخبارات الروسي
والامريكي مؤخرا جارت اتصالات بينهما في
تركيا هناك ايضا اتصالات مستمر على مستوى
رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه للجيش الروسي
وهمم نظرائه الغربيين وبالتالي هناك ربما
خطوات تتخذ من قبل كل الاطراف لتفادي همم
اسوى سيناريو ممكن قال وهو طبعا استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه كل الاطراف
تدرك اهميه وخطوره هذا الملف وبالتالي
عليها ان تتجنب استخدام هذه الاسلحه
المحلل السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك
في ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه ايضا وصل
الرئيسكي الى بولندا قادما من الوقت
المتحده في طريقه الى اكياس وعقد ذلك
مباحثات مع رئيس البولندي اندريه دودا
فورا استقباله بالمطار
عدم ارتداء زينسكي بدله رسميه عند لقائه
جو بايدن بالبيت الابيض اثارت استفزاز بعض
الامريكيين الذين انتقدوا الرئيس
الاوكراني واعتبر العديد من المعلقين
المحافظين ان عدد عدم ارتداء البدله علامه
على عدم احترام والتقدير من طرفيزنسكي
وذلك من منطلق ان الرؤساء وزعماء العالم
مما يزورون البيت الابيض
يرتدون الزي الرسمي على عكس البعض الذي
برر التصرف زنسكي بسبب الحرب التي تشهدها
بلاده وبالتالي لم يعطي للمظهر اهميه
بالغه في لقائه مع بيضا
ارتدى صوت راكاكيه اللون وهو المظهر الذي
تعمد ارتداؤه منذ بدايه العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه في فبراير الماضي
[موسيقى]
ومع تواصل العمليات العسكريه الروسيه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي تدخل شهرها
التاسع كشف وزير التحول الرقمي الاوكراني
على او عن ان قراصنه الاوكرانيين يساعدون
في توفير معلومات استقباريه مهمه بشان
افراد الجيش الروسي تساعد في اتخاذ
القرارات على ساحه المعركه وقال المسؤول
الاوكراني ان اعضاء ما يسمى بجيش الاي تي
الاوكراني يجمعون معطيات لتصنيف الجنود
الروس الذين يقتلون ويعذبون الاوكرانيين
كما انهم قاموا بتوثيق حوادث الاختراق
روسيه في اطار خطه لمحاكمه القاده الروس
امام المحاكم الدوليه وفقه تقرير نشارته
صحيفه واشنطن بوست
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الاركان الروسيه جنرال فاليري
جيراسيموف ان طول الجبهه في منطقه
العمليات العسكريه باوكرانيا وصل الى
815 كيلو مترا مشيرا في كلمه امام
الملحقين العسكريين الاجانب الى ان الجهود
الرئيسيه للقوات الروسيه تتركز حاليا على
سيطره على دوناسك دوناتسك واضاف
لرسموف ان المناورات البحريه مع الصين
جاءت ردا على الممارسات الامريكيه التي
وصفها بالعدوانيه في اسيا
فرضت الولايات المتحده عقوبات على عشره
كيانات بحريه روسيه بسبب استهدافها
الموانئ الاوكرانيه جاء ذلك في وقت قال
مسؤول بالبيت الابيض ان شركه فاكبير
الروسيه الخاصه نقلت اسلحه كوريه شماليه
الى روسيا لاستخدامها في اوكرانيا واشار
الى ان الشحنه تضامنت صواريخ وقذائف لقوات
المشاه الروسيه مؤكدا ان هذه الاسلحه لن
تغير من وقائع المعركه في اوكرانيا لكنه
هناك قلقا من تسليم المزيد
اعلن الادعاء العام الالماني القبض على
موظف المخابرات الخارجيه الالمانيه يعمل
جاسوسا لصالح روسيا وذكرت تقارير المانيه
انه ليس من الواضح حجم المعلومات التي
سربها الموظف المعتقل الى روسيا خاصه انه
كان يعمل لصالحها منذ وقت طويل وافادت
التقارير بان هذا الموظف تم اعتقاله امس
من قبل القوات الخاصه
[موسيقى]
الاستقلال العسكري الاوروبي بعيدا عن
امريكا هاجسون لا يفارقوا الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل الذي يصره على فكره تشكيل جيش
اوروبي مستقل عن الناتو فكره يحاول لبن
يصير معكروم على اقناع القاده الاوروبيين
بها مكرونه عبر وسيله امريكيه وهي وصيه
جانل عبر عما بداخله تجاه واشنطن مشددا
على ان القاره العجوز بحاجه الان لاكثر من
اي وقت مضى لتقليل الاعتماد على امريكا من
كل نواحي وهو ما يراهم محللون غربيون خطوه
يمكن ان تغير في مسار العلاقات الفرنسيه
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
اذا المساعد دبلوماسيه التي حملها مكرو في
زيارته الاخيره لوشنطن بخصوص الحرف
اوكرانيا يمكن ان لا ترى النور خصوصا وان
مواقفه اتجاه روسيا تغيرت وهو ما اثار غضب
اوكرانيا وبعض حلفائها بعد ان شدد على
ضروره تقديم ضمانات امنيه لروسيا كجزء من
اي مفاوضات فالتصريحات العلنيه للرئيس
الفرنسي تراها واشنطن غير مبرره خصوصا
وانه اكد في اكثر من مناسبه بان الولايات
المتحده لن تحترم دول اوروبا كحلفاء الا
اذا كانت شؤونها ادفعيه ذات سياده
لا يجب الاعتماد على الحلف بل يجب العمل
معه حتى نتمكن من اعاده التفكير في
استقلاليه
في عام 2018 لتاسيس جيش اوروبي موحد بعيد
عن حلف شمال الاطلسي ومستقل عن اي نفوذ
امريكي من السري الى العلم كما وصف الناتو
بالحلف الميت سريريا وهو ما اثار حفيظه
الولايات المتحده التي تعتبر نفسها عنصرا
مهما
على الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يبدا محادثته
الخاصه مع روسيا بدلا من الاعتماد على
واشنطن لتجنب اكثر الامور ماساويه في
الحرب
بضروره تشكيل جيش الاوروبي ذلك من خلال
تقديم مخطط عسكري يهدف الى تشكيل اول وحده
عسكريه تشمل 5000 عسكري مدعومه بسفن
وطائرات حربيه
واسلحه ثقيله يطلق عليها اسم قوه الدخول
الاول
وبالتالي فهو يسعى لتهميش دوري امريكا في
القضايا الاوروبيه اذ لم ينسى الرئيس
الفرنسي صفقه الغواصات لاستراليا التي
اعتبرتها باريس بمثابه خيانه عظمى لها
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من باريس دكتور زياد ماجد
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه في باريس اهلا بك دكتور زياد هل
فعلا مكروه هذه المره يبحث عن سياسه
خارجيه جديده في ملف العلاقه مع امريكا
والنائب النفس عن الناتو مع انه يعتبر
يعتبر ان نيته ميت سريريا
اعتقد ان هناك مسعد جدي من قبل مكروه يريد
ان يظهر من خلاله ان فرنسا تشبه الان ما
كان يريد شارك دو جول ان يبنيهك دور دولي
او عالمي لها بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بشكل مستقل عن اولويات وسياسات واشنطن لكن
في نفس الوقت يدرك مكروه ان دون ذلك
صعوبات جمع من ضمنها حجم فرنسا
الديموغرافي حجمها الاقتصادي عالميا وعدم
قدرتها على اقناع الكثير من شركائها
الاوروبيين بجدول هذا المشعر وما يكلفه
هذا الماء ماليا وعلى سعيد التصنيع
العسكري وموازنات الدفاع وغيرها لكن من
الضروري الاشاره الى ان تصريح مكروه حول
الموت السريري لحلف شمال الاطلسي كان ضمن
فتره التوتر اوروبي امريكي في عهد دونالد
ترامب الذي بنفسه كما يريد ان تدفع امريكا
اقل لحلف شمال الاطلسي واعتبره انذاك بغير
جدوى وكان يريد سحب قوات من المانيا ايضا
وكل ذلك موضوع البركزيت او او ترافق ذلك
موضوع البريكست فكانت فرنسا يومها تقول ان
اوروبا عليها الاتكال على نفسها اكثر من
السابق لا انت مثلا
الاوروبيه القاره العجوز او المعرفه اقله
بالصناعات العسكريه يريد ان يستبدل بقوه
اوروبيه طيب هل بقدرته دول اوروبا برايك
القيام بذلك
لا هو لا يريد ان يستبدل الناتو تماما
بقوه اوروبيه يريد ان يكون هناك قوه
اوروبيه مرادفه او على الاقل
من دون العوده الى قياده النيتو التي طبعا
تبسط امريكا عليها لكن تم
تفضل مساله مرتبطه بالموازنه مرتبطه بح
جمه من دولها تفرض الخدمه العسكريه
الالزاميه
ترتبط وجهات حول لا جدوى وجود صناعات
عسكريه وذخائر في دول تستطيع
النووي او على مظله
امريكا لا يوجد اجباع اوروبي
حتى
هل ممكن ايضا من تصريحات ماكرو ان نقول ان
اوروبا تعبت من الحرب في اوكرانيا لانه
امريكا تقرر واوروبا تدفع الثمن في في
البرد وفي اسعار الطاقه وايضا التضخم يعني
كلام مكروه انه اقله في سياسه الحرب في
اوكرانيا يجب ان يكون هناك تنازلات هل
بدانا ان نشعر هناك تميز عن الموقف
الامريكي تجاه الحرف في اوكرانيا
عن الموقف الامريكي لانه كان الوحيد الذي
ابقى صله وصل مع فلازم يفوتين من خلال
اتصالات هاتفيه دوريه وهذا اثار احيانا
غضبا لدى حلفاء اوروبي
وفرنسا الان نعم تريد ان تظهر مجددا انها
تستطيع اللعب دور ويصاقه وان هناك ضروره
لحل سياسي وليس فقط لاكتظام عسكري لكن حتى
قبل الحديث عن واشنطن يمكن القول ان دول
اوروبا الشرقيه مثلا بولندا وغيرها وحتى
المانيا لا
تتبع هذا وتعتبر ان
الحرب الروسيه هو المقدمه لاي شيء من دون
ان يكون هناك حديث عن ضمانات لان الموضوع
لا يرتبط بضمانات بلبي وقف الاشتياح
الروسي لاوكرانيا فلان ربي احد لكن طبعا
مع الوقت همم كما تفضلت ايضا يعني مساله
العامل الاقتصادي واسعار الطاقه وغيرها
سيكون لها اثر على المواقف الاوروبيه لكن
حتى الان ما زالت الاولويات هي وقف
العدوان الروسي في معظم العواصم الاوروبيه
الحديث معك دائما ولكن الوقت همنا من
باريس استاذ استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه الامريكيه في باريس
وتتابعونا في اخبار المساء ولكن بعد قليل
في الاحتجاجات الايرانيه المشاهير في مرمى
النظام السجن للمعارضين وللامتيازات
للمؤيدين
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد واخبار المساء مستمره
ونتابع من المانيا يعاني الجيش الالماني
قصورا كبيرين في المعدات لدى الاكثر من
ذلك انه اذا ثلثي السلاح المدفعيه معطل
ولا يعمل طبعا وفقا لمعلومات كشافتها
تايمز البريطانيه التي تقول انما معدات
القوات المسلحه الالمانيه في حاله سيئه
وذلك في حين بدات برلين سد بعض الثغرات في
قدراتها من خلال صندوق لاعاده التسليح
بقيمه 100 مليار يورو ياتي هذا الحديث اثر
ايام من تعطر مجموعه كامله من مركبات
القتاليه في اثناء التدريب خلال احدى مهام
حلف حلف شمال الاطلسي النيته ومن بين تلك
الاسلحه اتكشفت قياده الفرقه 10 مدرعه في
الجيش الالماني عن مشاكل
نيه متعدده مع مركبات المشاه القتاليه من
طراز بوما خلال اختبار اطلاق النار
والقتال لتدريبات النيتو الاخيره لذلك
اوقفت الدفاع الالمانيه شرائها حاليا وكان
من المفترض ان تكون بوما العمود الفقري
لقوه المهام المشتركه التابعه للنيتو
وتقودها المانيا وهي وحده من المفترض
نشرها بسرعه لحمايه الجبهه الشرقيه
للتحالف في حال حدوث غزو مدافع الحوتسر
ذاتيه الدفع والتي جاورتها برلين ومع ذلك
من بين ال 105 من الهوت سر الالمانيه فقط
ثلاثه وسبعون متوفره للجيش بحسب تقرير
حكوميه داخلي ويقال ان حواله نصف تلك
الانظمه قيد الاستخدام في ما يتم اصلاحه
18 اخرى لدى ورش صناعه الاسلحه
حتى في اوكرانيا ارسل ما لا يقل عن سته من
الحوت الالماني من اصل 14 مدفعا تم
تقديمها للجيش الاوكراني للاصلاح في
ليتوانيا وسط حاله نقص بقطع الغيار
[موسيقى]
الى ملف ايران رساله شديده اللهجه وجهها
مدير التلفزيون الايراني للفنانين
المعارضين لنظام في طهران وتوعدهم
بالمعاقبه معتبرا ان موقف الفنانين
المؤيدين للاحتجاجات الاخيره خيانه ولا
يتمشى مع رغبه غالبيه الشعب هذا بالنسبه
لمؤيديه الاحتجاجات اما مؤيدين نظام
ومنتقدي الاحتجاجات فقد تلقوا امتيازات من
النظام حيث قال رئيس التلفزيون الايراني
من البلاد ستدعم الاعمال والتعاون مع
اولائك الممثلين الذين لم يتخذوا مواقف ضد
النظام الايراني وسيتم تقديم جميع
الامكانيات الاعلاميه لهم
[موسيقى]
شبح والاعتقالات وتهديدات الذي يطال
الشخصيات الفنيه والرياضيه والطبق المثقفه
من قبل نظام خامنئي لا يزال متواصلا ومن
ابرز هذه الشخصيات البارزه هي الممثله
الايرانيه ترانا علي دوستي التي تتمتع
بشهره عالميه لمشاركتها في افلام نالت
جوائز عالميه حيث قامت الاجهزه الامنيه
الايرانيه بايقافها على خلفيه منشورات
داعمه للاحتجاجات للمحتاجين والتي
والمحتاجين والتي تنادد باعدام متظاهرين
وضعتها في منصات التواصل الاجتماعي كما تم
اعتقاله لاعب كره القدم الكردي وري غفوري
في فريق
خوزستان بتهمه القيامه بالسلوك مخزي
وتحريض ضد النظام وفقما تداولته وسائل
اعلام ايرانيه
ومن بين الشخصيات المؤثره التي اعتقلها
النظام الايراني كان المغني والملحن شرفين
حاجبور والذي اوذلك بعد ثمانيه 48 ساعه من
طرحه عمل فني
يعبر عن انتفاضه المراه
السلطات الامنيه في ايران اعتقلت ايضا
الممثله والمخرجه سهيله كالستاني والمخرج
المسرح حميد بور ازري بعد ان نشر مقطع
فيديو ظهرت فيه مجموعه من النساء الناشطات
في مجال المسرح دون الحجاب الاجباري
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من بروكسال قصي الدوره في
الباحث في شان الايراني اهلا بك هناك
العشرات والمئات واحيانا الالاف من
الشوارع في الشوارع في ايران لماذا يخيف
النظام الايراني ممثله هنا مخرج هناك لاعب
كره قدم هنا شخص واحد بالمجال العام يخيف
هؤلاء احيانا اكثر من
عشرات
تحياتي لكم المشاهدين احنا نشوف
المتظاهرين المتواجدين بالشارع اللي
يناشدون بيسقاط النظام
الاغلبيه من هؤلاء المتظاهرين ليس لديهم
اي شيء
ليخسرهم وصلوا لذروه لذروتهم بالحياه
يقولون ليس لدينا حياه كريمه ليس لدينا
اهداف همم
مستقبليه في ايران وليس لدينا كل شيء
نخساره فهم هم هم معرضين همم
اما امثال ترى انا على الديوثتي اول
ممثلين او اللاعبين كره القدم هم يديهم
الاف او ربما ملايين متابعين كمثال على
دوست لديها اكثر من ثمانيه مليون متابعه
انستغرام هي امراه بالدرجه الاولى هي
الثوره امراه فهي امراه تعاني من هذا
الشيء وايضا لديه كل شيء لتخسره فوجودها
كمحترضه همم كممثله عالميه لها صيده داخلي
وخارجي يرعب النظام الملالي ويقول و وربما
يفكر الناس ستكون ايقونه
لهذه المظاهره فلذلك امثالها وامثال بقيه
اللعيبه غد همم يعني همم احتغالها اولي
همم يكلف النظام اكثر من اعتقال الناس ال-
ال- الموجودين بالشارع ولكن احنا نشوف
عندما تصل الحكومه الى هذه النقطه ان
تعتقلها هؤلاء همم المؤثرين عالميين ن- ن-
نتابعه
ونركز ان الحكومه وصلت الى مرحله لا
الرجوع الى الوراء
يعني نقول دائما ان لدى النظام الايراني
القوه ربما بالقمح والقتل ولكن ايضا القوه
في دفع الاموال في تقديم الخدمات رشوات
والمثال واضح في سوريا الحرب من 2011 عدد
من الناس في الطبقه المثقفه همم اصحاب
الراي العام لم يعارض النظام الاسد ومع
الوقت قال لا يزال الاسد موجود نفس
الموضوع يطبق ايضا في ايران ايه هل بامكان
كل هؤلاء ان يعارضوا نظام لديه ادوات
النجاح ايضا من مال ومن فرص عمل
هم هم بالفعل النظام لديه هذه الادوات من
دفع المال والرشاوي وفعل هذا وفعلها هذا
الشيء مع الممثلين
واللعيبه في الماضي في ثورات كثيره في
ثوره 2019 في ثروه 2017 لم يتقدم او لم
يتكلم كثيرا من هؤلاء لانه شطاء بشكل
عالميض النظام لكن الان
يعني حتى هؤلاء الممثلين وصلوا لذروتهم
ولا ولا ولا ولا يمكن لهم ان يختاروا
الشعب همم
يختاروا الحكومه على الشعب هم يعلموا انهم
كسبوا مشروعيتهم محبوبيتهم ومكانتهم
الاجتماعيه من الشارع من هذا الشعب فيجب
عليهم ان يصطفوا بجانب ال بجانب ال- همم
الشعب ربما او بال- بالسنوات الماضيه كان
يقولون نحن فنانين نحن اللعيبه الكره ليس
ليس اعمالنا عمل سياسي ولا يدخل بالعمل
السياسي لكن الان هذا الشيء غير مقبول من
الشارع عندما تلعب وتمثل بلادك يجب عليك
ان ان يكون لك رايك الخاص هذا شي شاهد من
خلال همم مباراه كاس العالم خلال مباراه
ايران في كاس العالم ان شفنا كثير او
القسم الاكبر من المجتمع الايراني لم يشجع
المنتخب الايراني فقط بسبب انهم وقفوا
بجانب النظام وهذا الشيء ايضا ينطب على
على الممثلين ايضا الايراني
[موسيقى]
في اخر التطورات المتعلقه بتشكيل الحكومه
في اسرائيل ابلغ بنيامين نتنياهو الرئيس
الاسرائيلي بانه تمكن من تشكيل الحكومه
فيما قال اعلام المحالي ان نتنياهو يريد
ان يؤدي او ان تؤدي الحكومه اليمين
القانونيه الخميس المقبل لكن هناك متسع
لان لان يحصل ذلك حتى الثاني من يناير
بسبب عدم توزيع الحقائب وتعتبر هذه المره
الاولى التي يراس فيها بنيامين نتانيا
الحكومه يمنيه خالص بدون احزاب وسط ويسار
جاء هذا في وقت انجز فيه اللي كود
الاسرائيلي الاتفاقيات او الاتفاقات
الائتلافيه مع حزبي الصهيونيه الدينيه
وقوى يهوديه ويشكوا على تواصل الاتفاقات
مع حزبين
وهترا وشاش الدينيه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الي من القدس زياد حلبي مراسل
العربيه زياد يعني كان من التوقع ان يشكل
نتنياهو حكومه بشكل مريح ولكن
وان تكون يمنيه متجانسه ولكن هذا تاخر
لماذا هذا التاخير ويعني ما الذي عرقل ااه
ووصل الى نهايه التفويض ولم يحصل ذلك
اهل الربا بدون ادنى شك بان شركاؤه
الايديولوجيين
والطبيعيين يمكن القول في اليمين واليمين
المتطرف وجدوها فرصه ثانيحه لتحقيق مطالب
ايدولوجيه عمرها عقود لم تكن تتحقق لولا
حاجه نتنياهو الماسه لهذه الاحزاب ولولا
كبار وقوه هذه الاحزاب نسبيا في التوليف
الحاكمه التي يعمل نتنياهو على انجازها
يعني عند قراءه الاتفاقات
الاختلافيه التي توصل اليها مع مثلا حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه وكذا ايضا مع القوه
اليهوديه برئاسه المتطرف بين كبير تقريبا
كل ما طلبوه تم الاستجابه له من احكام
بالاعدام من ممثلين العمليات فلسطينيه همم
بالاضافه الى شرعناه البؤر الاستيطانيه
بالعشرات في الدفاع الغربيه
المحتله منعرف العالم الفلسطيني واللائحه
تطول من المطالب اليمنيه التي طرحوها قبلت
كلها همم لانه وفق مراقبين نتنياهو عمليا
يريد الان ان يمرر بعض التشريعات خاصه
التي تطال القضاء الاسرائيلي وتضعف هذا
القضاء لصالح ربما
محاكمته بقضايا الفساد ولهذا هو يحاول
استرضاء هذه الاحزاب حتى على حساب حساب
لكود الذي يتنمر من ان ال- ال- يعني
الهدايا الدسمه ذهبت الى الشركاء
يعني دائما لما يكون فيه من نتنياهو في
مفاجات اقله في السياسه الخارجيه ماذا
امامنا مع حكومه يمنيه خالصه في السياسه
الخارجيه وايران هي على هذا الوضع وكل ما
يجري في المنطقه
سيؤثران على العلاقات الخارجيه الامر
الاول هو بدون شك بان هذه الحكومه الواضح
بانها ستذهب الى نوع من الصدام مع
الفلسطينيين ستحاول همم الضفه الغربيه
المحتله ستصطدم باوروبا والولايات المتحده
وهنا يحذر خبراء استراتيجيون في اسرائيل
من مغبه هذا الامر لان ذلك سيضعف عمليا
محاوله الحكومه او حاجه اسرائيل اللاحقه
بمساعده امريكيه في مواجهه ايران اذا
محتاجه الضربه للمنشات وما الى ذلك لا
يمكنها ان تفعل ذلك عندما تغضب اداره او
تصطدم مع الاتحاد الاوروبي ولهذا عمليه
التوقعات في اسرائيل بان همم نتنياهو
سيبقى وفيا للعلاقه المتوتره مع البيت
الابيض اقله في السنتين المقبلتين حيث ان
اداره ستبقى مكانها
شكرا دائما لك زياد حلبي لكل هذه
المعلومات والتحليلات القيمه مراسل
العربيه من القدس
[موسيقى]
الى افغانستان حيث طردت حركه طالبان فتيات
من المعاهد النسائيه والمكتبات ثم اغلقوها
كجزء من قرار الحركه الجديد بمنع نساء من
اكمال التعليم الجامعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لا
[موسيقى]
وفي المواقف الدوليه ادانا وزراء وخارجيه
مجموعه السبع بشده قرار منع الفتيات من
التعليم في افغانستان معتبرين في هذا
الفتيات يرقى الى جريمه ضد الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
طالبان تحرق يوما بعد يوم وبيدها لا بيد
غيرها كرتنتلو الاخر لانهاء عزلتها
الدوليه
فالحركه التي ظهرت والى التسعيليات من
القرن الماضي الى ان برز نجمها في
افغانستان خليفه عام
1994 الى الان تعيد دوران عقارب الساعه
عكس اتجاهها
حكم الطالبان افغانستان للمره الاولى في
الفتره من
1996 وحتى العام 2001 ووعدت حينها باحلال
السلام والامن والاحترام حقوق الانسان
بمجرد وصولها للسلطه ذلك ما لم يتحقق حضر
الطالبان مشاهده التلفزيون والاستماع الى
الموسيقى وارتياد الدور السينما ورفضت
الذهاب الفتيات من سن العاشره الى المدارس
ودخلت لحركه في عزله دوليه كبيره تمت
الاطاحه حينها بطالبان ولاحقتها تهم
ارتكاب انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان
ودخلت في حرب الواسعه النطاق ثم لا حسوا
الحركه مجددا خلال سنوات القليله الماضيه
في افغانستان حيث توفرت فرصه اخرى في ظل
محاوله الغرب دعمها وخلق مساحه للمفاوضات
عادت الحركه الجديده عقب انسحاب القوات
الامريكيه من البلاد العام الماضي
وبسطت سيطرتها بالكامل وفي خضم اعاده الدم
الحركه كان الحديث في ذلك الوقت المطالبه
بتقديم المساعده من المجتمع الدولي وفق
تعهدات للمجتمع الافغاني والعالمي وهي
تعهدات لم تحقق منها الحركه شيئا ومنها ما
تم مؤخرا من حظر الدراسه الجامعيه على
الفتيات
هو كان التاريخ يعيد نفسه من جديد اضاع
الطالبان فرصه من يدها وقطعت شوط اخر
للوراء عصام عبد السلام العربيه
البريطانيه تصر على تنفيذ خطه نقل
اللاجئين الى رواندا لتسويه طلباتهم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ونتابع نشره المساء على
خطه طالبان بتضيق الخناق على النساء تمارس
مليشيات الحوثي ذات الانتهاكات في مناطق
سيطرتها عبير المقتري طالبه يمنيه حصلت
على منحه دراسيه في مصر لكن الميليشيات
حرمتها من تحقيق حلمها نتابع
بينها وبين الحلم بالدراسه حلم بالعبور
الى البلد المقصود تحاول القبضه الحوثيه
تحطيما عبير المكتري شابه يمنيه من محافظه
تعز ارادت استكمال تحصيلها العلمي في مصر
بعد حصولها على منحه دراسه هناك
لكنني ميليشيات الحوثي ابتساماح لها بذلك
ربما ليقينها بوهان رصاصها امام قوه رصاص
قلم بين انامل عبير
فلاحقتها وغلقت الابواب امامها فلم يعد
بامكانها المغادره لا جوا عبر مطار صنعاء
ولا برا باتجاه مطار عدن بعد ما جتني منحه
القاهره
من قبل الحوثيين في مطار صنعاء
فقلت اسافر بدل ما اسافر من مطار صنعاء
اسافر من مطار عدن
وانا بطريقي لعدم تم نعيم مره ثانيه من
قبل الحوثيين القصه هي عبير ومسيلاتها
القصه هي المراه اليمنيه بل اكبر القصه
شعب مرتهن بقبضه ميليشيا تجبرت بالسلاح
فسامحت لمواليها ومنعت عن الاخرين وما من
سبيل سوى الكلمه
عبر الكتابه وفضح هذه الاساليب واستنكارها
او عبر التواصل مع المجتمع الدولي في حاله
انه يستطيع الضغط على هذه المليشيات عبير
مثالها كمثل شابه افغانيه او صدق الطالبان
ابواب الجامعات والمدارسونه لان امراه
متعلمه ستنشئ جيلا سيرهق بوعيه حاكمه
حوثيا كان ام من طالبان ام اخرين يوم
نجلاس العربيه
[موسيقى]
شهد المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الخارجيه التركي
مولود شاويش اوغلو ونظيره السويدي
وفنلندا لم تقوم حتى اليوم بما يلزم
بمعالجه المخاوف تركيا بشان ايواء مطلوبين
وجماعات مرتبطه بالارهاب
الكردستاني الى بلادنا وقد تم اتخاذ هذه
الاجراءات للوصول الى الطريق الصحيح لكن
لا يوجد تقدم ملحوظ فيما يتعلق بابعاد
الارهابيين وتجميد اصول الاعمال الارهابيه
النهارده
وزير الخارجيه السويدي بالتاكيد على ان
تسليم المطلوبين يخضع للقانون وان بلاده
ملتزمه بمعالجه المخاوف التركيه وفقا
لاتفاقيه ثلاثيه للانضمام الى حلف الناتو
وانها مستمره في تبادل المعلومات مع تركيا
في هذا الصدد
[موسيقى]
السويد لديها قضاء مستقل يقوم بمراجعه
جميع القضايا وكما تعلمون وبالنظر الى
سؤالك منذ توقيع المذكرات الثلاثيه يعتبر
التعاون العملي بين الشرطه السويديه وجهاز
الامن من اولوياتهما وقد لا يشكل حزب
العمال الكردستاني تهديدا كبيرا للسويد
لكنه بالتاكيد يمثل تهديدا لتركيا وهو امر
تاخذه الحكومه السويديه على محميه
[موسيقى]
الى بريطانيا اعتبر تاييد المحكمه العليا
في لندن ترحيل المهاجرين غير الشرعيه الى
رواندا انتصارا كبيرا لوزاره الداخليه
التي تصر على ان سياسه الترحيل ضروريه
لوقف ازمه القوارب الصغيره المميته
القادمه من فرنسا فيما يدرس المدافعون عن
اللاجئين تقديم طعن في القرار الذي سيمدد
المعركه القضائيه
طالب اللجوء الكردي صباح حسن من بين الذين
يواجهون امكانيه الترحيل الى رواندا بعد
انقضت المحكمه العليا في لندن بقانونيه
ابعاد مهاجرين دخلوا بريطانيا بطرق غير
نظاميه الى العاصمه الروانديه والنظر في
ملفات لجوءهم هناك اللاجئون والمنظمات
المعنيه بشئونهم عبروا عن قلقهم الشديد
ايذاء هذا القرار
بصراحه هذا قرار سيء جدا
ستكون امنه او غيره امنه هذه المجموعه
الكرديه من طالب اللجوء اتت لتستفسر من
احد اعضاء الجمعيه الكرديه لندن بشان
تداعيات تاييد المحكمه العليا لتسويه
طلبات الراغبين باللجوء على بعد الاف
الاميال من بريطانيا
لحقوق الانسان يمكنها وقف الترحيل الى
روندا وهناك عقيل اخرى قبل ذلك فالمصار
القضائي ليس نهائيا القرار
الخطه المثيره للانتقادات بابعاد الاجئين
وصلوا بريطانيا بطرق غير نظاميه الى
رواندا تبنتها حكومه جونسون باتفاقيه مع
نظيرتها في كيغالي لوقف رحلات عبور البحر
الخطيره لالاف المهاجرين من فرنسا الى
الجزيره البريطانيه ترحيل اول دفعه من
ثمانيه لاجئين الغيت الصيف الماضي بعد
تدخل المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان لكن
وزيره الداخليه السولارما مصره على مواصله
سياسه الترحيل في اقرب وقت ممكن
تبيعات هذا القرار غير الانساني وفور وصول
اللاجئين لايوائهم قد ينقلون الى بلد لا
نعرفها
كسب وزاره الداخليه تاييد المحكمه لنقل
اللاجئين الى افريقيا للبث في طلباتهم
يضعوا على طريق تنفيذ خطتها التي لا تزال
حبر على ورق وكلفت دفع الضرائب حتى الان
120,000,000 جنيه وقد تتطلب عده اشهر
لتنفيذها بعد انتهاء المسار القضائي مصطفى
زارو العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
موظفي بالاستعداد لما وصفه بمعركه ماساويه
مع فايروس كورونا حيث يتوقع اصابات نصف
سكان المدينه البالغ عددهم 25 مليون نسمه
بحلول نهايه العام وفق رويترز ويجتاح
الفيروس الصين دون رابع اسراء تحولها
لملجا
اثرا تحول لها عن سياسه صفر
[موسيقى]
كشف تقرير صادر عن صحيفه واصل الجمل ان
خدمه البث الشهيره
لمشاركه كلمات المرور باسو من اوائل عام
2023 وجاء هذا بعد ان كانت نتفليكس تحاول
البحث عن طرق للقضاء عليها بحجه انها تمثل
مشكله تؤثر على ارباحها ومع انخفاض
الايرادات هذا العام وخساره نتفليكس لاول
مره منذ 10 سنوات قرر رئيس التنفيذي
للشركه انه حان الوقت لتصرف بشان هذه
المشكله التي تم تاجيلها لفتره طويله جدا
[موسيقى]
هذا وقفه مع ابرز احداث مارس هذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلي اليوم
في هذه اللحظه التاريخيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ختام اخبار المساء وهذا ابرز ما جاء فيها
الرئيس
اوكرانيا
معكرونه يوصلوا على الاستقلال العسكري عن
الولايات المتحده ويجدد الدعوه لانشاء جيش
اوروبي
[موسيقى]
طلاب وجامعات افغانستان ينسحبون احتجاجا
على منع الطالبات من التعليم والطالبان
تمنع الفتيات في المعاهد والمكتبات
انا اعود والقاكم يوم الاحد والان الى
العربيه 360 مع زميله راويه مساء الخير
الكلمه لك مساء الخير ريما شكرا جزيلا